as a side note
let me say that one small but powerful
idea that jeff hawkins mentions in his
new book
is that if human civilization were to
destroy itself
all of knowledge all our creations will
go with us
he proposes that we should think about
how to save that knowledge
in a way that long outlives us whether
that's on earth
in orbit around earth or in deep space
and then to send messages that advertise
this backup of human knowledge
to other intelligent alien civilizations
the main message of this advertisement
is not
that we are here but that we were
once here this little difference
somehow was deeply humbling to me that
we may
with some non-zero likelihood destroy
ourselves and that an alien civilization
thousands or millions of years from now
may come across this knowledge store
and they would only with some low
probability even notice it
not to mention be able to interpret it
and the deeper question here
for me is what information in all of
human knowledge is even essential
does wikipedia capture it or not at all
this thought experiment
forces me to wonder what are the things
we've accomplished
and are hoping to still accomplish that
will outlive us
is it things like complex buildings
bridges cars rockets
is it ideas like science physics and
mathematics
is it music and art is it
computers computational systems or even
artificial intelligence systems
i personally can't imagine that aliens
wouldn't already have
all of these things in fact much more
and much better to me the only unique
thing we may have
is consciousness itself and the actual
subjective experience of suffering
of happiness of hatred of love
if we can record these experiences in
the highest resolution directly from the
human brain
such that aliens will be able to replay
them that
is what we should store and send as a
message
not wikipedia but the extremes of
conscious experiences
the most important of which of course is
love
you